a partir de hoy 10 de mayo los médicos
especialistas de hospitales públicos de
madrid están en huelga indefinida piden
que el gobierno de la región acabe con
la alta temporalidad que sufre el sector
que afecta a más de la mitad de la
plantilla y al 82% de quienes trabajan
en urgencias aunque pueda parecer una
jornada normal a mis espaldas más de
11.000 sanitarios estaban convocados a
la huelga sin embargo los servicios
mínimos establecidos por el gobierno de
madrid del 100% en servicios críticos y
urgentes y del 50% en otras
especialidades han hecho muy difícil que
todos puedan acceder a su derecho a
hacer huelga pese a que hace tan sólo
cinco meses entró en vigor en españa'
una reforma laboral que pretendía
terminar precisamente con los contratos
temporales y aunque la medida ya está
dando resultados favorables en otros
sectores en el médico aún no se ha
beneficiado desde el propio ámbito
sanitario lo califican como la mayor
empresa de trabajo temporal de españa'
con médicos que llevan décadas
encadenando un contrato temporal tras
otro los médicos piden que los aplausos
recibidos cada día durante la pandemia
lleguen ahora en apoyo a una huelga para
mejorar el sistema sanitario público de
la capital de españa por otro lado hoy
también se activó la línea 0 24 de
prevención del suicidio que es la mayor
causa de muerte no natural en españa' y
la principal causa de muerte en jóvenes
antes sólo existían iniciativas locales
o sectoriales pero no un servicio
público esta línea de atención a la
conducta suicida se ha financiado
gracias a los fondos de la unión europea